they commissionaire without further ado
floor is yours
well thank you very much before turning
to today's decision I would very much
like to use this opportunity to
congratulate Lucilla fonda lion on her
election by the European Parliament
Tuesday it is indeed historic we now
have the first president elects a woman
for the European Commission and I look
very much forward to working with Ursula
and I find a lot of inspiration in her
guidance and what's launched is setting
for the next Commission I'm here though
today to take about talk about a
decision that we have taken so today the
Commission has decided to find kwok-him
242 million euros for an
anti-competitive behavior that is
illegal under EU antitrust rules our
case concerns baseband chip says they
are the chipsets that are compliant with
3G standards and mainly used in mobile
open devices investigation found that
quick and blocked competition by
applying predatory prices to protect its
dominance EU competition rules do not
prevent dominant companies like Qualcomm
from offering low prices to their
customers but dominant companies they
have a special responsibility not to
impair competition in the internal
market they can sell and low prices but
they cannot sell below costs with the
intention of eliminating a competitor
this is not competition on the merits
while such predatory pricing can lead to
low prices in the short term customers
are worse off in the long run because
once the victim of the predatory
strategy is marginalized
or leave the markets well then a
dominant company is no longer challenged
by competition and will try to recoup
what it has lost by raising prices and
slowing down investment and innovation
to the detriment of consumers you
probably right now have a baseband
chipset in your pockets or in your back
there in all smart firms there are all
tablets that we use every day
thanks to this vital components mobile
devices can connect to mobile networks
so that we can make phone calls so we
can access the Internet baseband chip
says they can also be part of external
modules such as data cards which are
plugged into devices which can then
connect to the internet these mobile
broadband devices were among the first
to offer high-speed mobile connectivity
allowing laptops and other devices to
connect between 2009 and 2011 5g
nonsence 3G was the most advanced
wireless technology standard at the time
kokum sold sixty percent of these
chipsets world wide there are
significant barriers to entry into this
market chipsets are very complex as
products they require high investments
in research and innovation the fact that
Wacom dominated the market is as such
not a problem under EU competition rules
we value companies for becoming
successful due to their skills due to
their innovation the problem is when a
company distorts competition against the
interests of consumers and the markets
as a whole our case began with a
complainant from a company called Ysera
this era was a small
startup which introduced its first
baseband chip set to the market in 2006
Aceros chipsets became an attractive
alternative to coax baseband chip sets
in particular those four data cards as a
result quote camp started seeing Ysera
as posing a real threats to its chipsets
business our investigation showed that
kokum identified the threat as critical
by 2010
kokom not only had a concern about the
growing success of acerous chipsets
for data cards it was also concerned
that Sarah would start offering 3d
chipsets for smartphones is Sarah's
success in the data card segment could
serve as a springboard to allow it to
compete in the far more significant and
profitable segment for chipsets for
smartphones to make sure that is Sarah's
business could not reach a size that
could endanger the market position of
kokum Qualcomm took what it describes in
internal documents preventive actions
this meant offering very targeted price
concessions to to strategically
important customers namely Huawei and
set te these were big customers of
chipsets for data cards and they were
essential for Sarah to succeed in the
market our investigation found that two
crucial years for Sarah's development
prospects kokum offered three of its
leading or chipping ads chipsets at
prices below cost to their key customers
the price is set by kokum did not allow
it to cover its cost for developing and
producing chipsets
the evidence that we have seen shows
that this was done on purpose it was
done on purpose to prevent a Sarah from
gaining a foothold in the market at a
time where Sarah was welcomes main
contender in the market segment for
chipsets for data cards as a results of
Calkins conduct he Sarah was prevented
from gaining reputation and scale as a
supplier of chipsets for data cards and
ultimately for entering the largest
smartphone segment it's Sarah did not
make it as a self-standing competitor in
the chipsets industry in 2011 it was
brought by Nvidia which decided to
abandon abandon the basement chips at
market a few years later becomes abusive
behavior also had a negative impact on
innovation by choking off Sarah's
revenues from the 3G business Qualcomm
deprived
ysera of fonts that it needed to develop
chipsets for the next wireless
generation the 4G standard Qualcomm did
not demonstrate that its conduct created
efficiencies that could justify it in
short quote comes behavior deprived
customers have a wide choice of
technologies and affected is Sarah's
ability to develop chipsets for the next
wireless technology generation and this
is why we find core cam 242 million
euros the fine reflects the seriousness
and the duration of the infringement
now predatory pricing is not a common
type of case in fact the last time the
Commission imposed a fine for such
behavior was 16 years ago but no matter
how difficult no matter how complex
these cases are we remain calm
to fighting predatory pricing by
dominant companies
moreover the decision today will support
any action for damages caused by
Qualcomm's anti-competitive behavior
before national courts in fact in cases
before national courts a commission
decision is a binding proof of the
behavior that it took place and that it
was illegal but it is true if you think
that it took some time for us to
conclude this case we opened the former
investigation and sent a statement of
objection to Co come back in 2015
since then we sent state we sent a
supplementary statement of objection to
kokum we helped to or hearings we
engaged in detailed exchanges with the
company concerning additional
information that was required for our
investigation kokum has also appealed
one of our information requests to the
general court and after losing in the
first instance appealed the decision to
the European Court of Justice these many
different procedural steps they are a
key part of the checks and balances that
ensure the procedural fairness of our
enforcement system but they do take time
we have made progress in this mandate in
expediting our antitrust procedures but
it is the challenge that will stay with
us for quite some time still just to
conclude this is the second antitrust
fine that we have imposed on Quokka
in 2018 we find the company 997 million
euros because it granted exclusivity
payments in both this that case and
today's case quorums objective was the
same to protect its dominant position
in relation to baseband chipsets to shut
out its rivals
similarly the Commission objective in
these cases is always the same
to protect European consumers to enable
choice the benefits of competition that
are so obvious choice affordable prices
and innovation thank you
Thank You commissioner we can now turn
to your questions starting with today's
decision and then we can broaden up a
little bit let me also point out that we
have quite a number of experts in the
room and we will start with Nicolas High
Commissioner Nicolas Hurst from mBLAQ's
so you said that this was that you
discovered evidence that this Joshi was
intentional and they were aware or they
were aiming to eliminate eliminate I
Syria did you uncover any evidence that
would suggest that Qualcomm knew it was
breaching EU rules but went ahead
regardless I did it knowingly break that
you competition rules duration and you
said it highly complex predatory pricing
many different steps in terms of
protecting the rights of Defense has
nonetheless has this case spurred any
thinking about steps that could be
taking in the future to ensure that
cases don't run for 10 years regardless
of all those those factors thank you
in one of the reasons why I think every
procedural step has become an issue is
of course that when you want to do a a
price cost test you need a lot of
information from a company and I would
think if I was the company that this is
quite an intrusive investigation because
you need a lot of numbers to do what is
called an EXO test so obviously sort of
our procedural steps and the substance
of the case have been intertwined this
is what is called I think the the second
AXA test because we found in the
internal documents prove of the
intention of the predatory pricing as
far as I know we didn't find any proof
that they know that it was illegal due
to European competition law and
obviously as you will see that we're
dealing with a US company versus a UK
company and two Asian companies who are
Winsett tui when you see the harm done
for computers was of course the the
device is sold in Europe but indirectly
via Huawei and ZTE
so it is quite complex also for the
businesses involved to see in what
jurisdiction a harm would be pursued and
investigated and I think that's as part
of the explanation as to why it has has
taken so long when I look at sort of the
statistics of our case work I think we
have made quite some improvements if you
look at the Google Adsense case and the
Google app Android case they were in
terms of antitrust cases relatively fast
if you look at the settlement on the
ebooks case with Amazon that was done
within two years time so in a number of
cases you can see that we speed up never
ever because we compromise on a fair
process but because we try to you know
for instance from the very first
document is put on the file to make sure
that we have thought through
how to allow access to file in an
expedient manner in this case I think
like forty thousand documents on file so
obviously it's very important that these
documents they are put in a in in the
file in an orderly manner so that you
have access to them if you receive a
statement of objection from us but
that's as part of the explanation as to
why we can be more expedite in some
other cases because of all these sort of
time saving procedures internally
finding a week there two weeks there a
months there in order to do things in a
more expedited way I don't think that we
will ever get over sort of the sort of
inbuilt dial Emma here which is that we
have a very strong incentive for
speeding up cases but those that we
investigate well very often will have
the opposite incentive which is to
withdraw not to withdraw but to prolong
the investigation country to murder
control we're both us and the companies
have the same time incentive to get the
investigation done and to get it over
with
thank you Eva from evil white from
Bloomberg a related question you
recently took interim measures against
Broadcom in a similar market chip market
which is in danger of tipping do you see
how quickly do you think those cases
need to move I mean we've seen some of
the national cases go within a couple of
months what's your target for bringing a
final decision an interim decision on
Broadcom
well I we hope to be able to do that
early autumn it is again of course
tricky because obviously it is also a
case to do interim measures if we would
want to order you to do interim measures
we would send you a statement of
objection we will of course protects and
enable your right to defend yourself
before we can take a decision on interim
measures and again we do this as fast as
possible because as you say if there is
a risk of a tipping market we have to be
there but we will always respect the
right to defend yourself but hopefully
if we are still find that we are right
to impose interim measures sometime
early autumn thank you then we attack
could I please remind you first to ask
your questions about today's case Thank
You commissioner hi caseta from power
just going back to the ice era case what
were the particular challenge is the
case team faced in finding evidence in
this case I asked this question because
the formal complaint was first launched
nine years ago in 2010
you yourself mentioned the last
predatory pricing case was done 16 years
ago was there any particular challenge
stemming from the fact that this company
went bust
also thank you no not really because the
evidence we needed was evidence coming
from kokum because it's with pokum we
need to show that the prices are set at
a predatory level and that is kind of
tricky because you know our sort of
natural instinct would to be happy about
low prices because then if you're a
customer in the value chain at the end
you can present affordable prices to
your end consumer but here of course
when it comes to predatory pricing cases
we need a lot of data from a company
either to do the xl1 test of the AXA to
test to show that you price below
average variable cost or aerobridge
to cost and in the two different
circumstance well it is quite
complicated to make sure that you get it
right depending of course what tests you
will make if you would then have to
attribute also part of the cost of the
company to these specific products
because a company like Wacom they do
more than base band chipsets and this is
why it is a challenge to do this because
obviously you can have a back and forth
about what kind of information can you
request what kind of information it is
proportional for you to request in order
for us to have the comfort that we have
done what we can to prove this case and
this is what makes predatory pricing
cases so challenging for us but I hope
that we can show by doing this case even
though it Sarah it's not on the market
anymore that you know what as a
deterrent that we stay vigilant when we
see traces of predatory pricing and
companies should think twice or maybe
they should not think about doing
predatory pricing because obviously we
have the willingness to investigate it
even though it is very challenging quick
follow on on the fine level since you
also mentioned deterrence I noticed the
press release says that it's set at one
point two seven percent of Qualcomm
stern over in 2018 I'm just curious as
to why it was one point two seven
percent when the conduct is as serious
as pushing a company out of business in
the Intel abuse of dominance case it was
set at four point one five percent so is
is to 242 million deterrent enough also
I wanted to note that Nvidia purchased
this company for three hundred and fifty
two million dollars in 2011 so I think
from the complainants side a question is
this is not this is not of fine that's
enough
well the first thing is that what we can
show is a case of predatory pricing but
we cannot show definitely that this was
what pushed in sera to be bought by
another company and pushed them
eventually out of the baseband chipset
market that we cannot show what we can
show is that predatory pricing took
place and the find reflects that this is
a relatively short duration of the
infringement of course you see that it's
a serious infringement which is of
course why there is some sense of
gravity even though it was short another
side of this case I think is important
when looking at the fine range is the
fact that here there is an a possibility
for private damages because assets our
decision today will work as proof in
national courts to say well this conduct
took place and it was illegal then it's
for the complainant in a national court
case to say what we were the victims of
this illegal conduct and that I think is
is part of it because not only do you
get a fine but you also get to prove
against you that you have done something
illegal and that proof can work with
others if they want to take you to a
court in and member-state looks at scene
yes to question the first one did ICA
ask for interim measures back in the
days the second question is when you ask
for supplementary evidence did you
already have proof that there was an
intent to drive the computer out of the
market on the first question to my
knowledge no there was no talk about
interim measures back in the days and
seconds from what I know from the
investigation well you got sort of the
two sets of evidence in a not sort of
serial order but coming in more or less
together so you see that out something
is wrong here they had an intention to
do something you see the prices as such
but then you have
to dig in to see the price level and to
fully understand how does that price
level compared to the cost of the
company you didn't have evidence before
the second round a clear evidence that
there was an intent of driving the
competitor hard evidence in cases like
this is evidence that comes from
analyzing and calculating the price cost
relationship so what you get from the
company is a lot of numbers on how do
they price thing how do they produce
thing what is the cost of getting there
and for us one of the things that were
beneficial for us in this case was the
fact that from the internal documents we
could see the intention that there was
an intention it was on purpose
what Qualcomm was doing and you see we
have these two different set of tests
that we have from practices from the
case law and we could then use the
second test because we both have proof
of the intention and we can see in the
numbers that they price below cost my
question referred to when you've got so
as I said in the documents you you
received you found the intention so it's
probably in the PowerPoint someone said
oh we need to keep them out of the
market the the question is when you
found this because the Qualcomm say that
the second the supplementary requests
for information you went fishing for
information you didn't have enough so my
question is did before the supplementary
request for information you've found in
the documents proof of intent which you
cannot find in the data or did you find
proof of intent while you receive the
document from this second alpha I I
don't know the exact timing of that but
I know that the general court have had
the first ruling they said well
the Commissioner was fine the ask of the
Commission first we asked the
information in a letter we didn't get
the information then we took a decision
to request the information that decision
was then appealed the court upheld our
request for information so the court at
least in first instance found that our
ask was proportional and that it was to
be requested that of course is not being
repealed this is why it's important for
me to say that the court in first
instance but so far we feel that we have
been doing this exactly by the book and
with no fishing expedition because part
of that of course is that we are
proportional in what we ask to be able
to do our casework sorry I machine that
we can move on to more general questions
now or are we still on specifically on
the case doesn't seem to my collection
from Analects first quite an easy
question with a simple yes or no answer
is it your desire to stay on as
Competition Commissioner under the next
Commission and secondly someone linked
to the first what discussions have you
had with the president-elect so far and
in particular has she given you any
assurances that you'll be placed on an
equal footing with France timmermans as
the two highest ranking vice presidents
and the next Commission well you know
I'm an I'm a middle-aged woman I've been
working with journalists for like thirty
years of my life and one thing that
makes me watch for is this is a very
simple question when you start like that
you know Oh be on your guard
I said I think now six months ago that
if there was anything I would like to do
it was to continue as commissioner for
competition I usually try to put a lid
on it but when I'm very happy with my
job because I hope it makes sense for
people and for the many many businesses
who compete on the merits that they see
that here
the European Union we do our best to
make sure that competition is fair so
it's a great job now of course things
are to some degree changed my own home
country and I'm very very grateful for
that has RINO Minh ate at me as a
commissioner in the agreement in in
council it was said that France
Timmerman and myself were to be highest
ranking and what was a LOF underline has
provided is indeed an equal footing on
the substance so that we can work
together for the Commission program to
be put into reality with the rest of the
college when finally we have a new
commission I am Natalie Ellis from M
luxe and I have a question about
Facebook I understand that the
Commission has sent out questionnaires
about Facebook and I was wondering what
is the concern that you're investigating
well it is indeed correct that we take
an interest
what investigative steps we have taken
so far I cannot comment any other
questions
Austrian TV and radio I have a question
concerning Galileo we heard that the
system was restored and however the the
Commission is trying to establish an
inquiry board to to kind of investigate
the roots of the problems
Commission it's I'm not sure if it's
right now is it that we can ask other
questions as well it's just like
competition cases I'm not sure midday
briefing because I'm as interested as
you but I really don't know the answer
the Commission said it wants to
establish an inquiry board to get to the
roots of the course of the problems what
we mean is that we can come to this
question during the midday briefing
which will start right after this press
conference go to my office and watch it
so that I get the answers well I think I
saw James yeah Martin Sal Myers is
stepping down next week according to
some reports given that he's in charge
of No Deal brexit planning does that
mean for veu is less prepared for a No
Deal brexit than it was before his
resignation how did you come up with
that question now I think no matter
who's who is on the teams we are
prepared also for another exits and we
have been that for quite some time and
that preparation of course stays as
relevant as it was when it was first
made okay you all know we have a midday
shortly do we have any final questions
for commissioner who she done
sorry I just have to ask this can you
give us the latest update on the
shopping remedy as well as the Android
remedy how many compliance reports have
been submitted by KPMG and mavens and
what do the recent traffic and click
data look like thank you
I don't keep count of the reports being
submitted to us the numbers move but
only very very slightly so the level is
basically the same and 75% of queries
you'd find a rival 40% of clicks with
one way or another go to a rival or a
merchant hosted by rival we will indeed
keep monitoring this saem's goes with
the androids remedy where the timing of
course is in the hands of of Google but
we of course stay vigilant because this
is a very important market for us but
there is no sort of further news than
that
I see Nicola is that for the
Commissioner I know that it's
exceptional for me to give up defense
subjects I'm from sued West and b2 I'd
like to say something about to Western
European countries who want to reform
competition rules they've been wanting
to do that for a long time you talked
about the priorities of the upcoming
Commission how do you view this
situation this desire to change
competition and how about would you
explain it well it's very important
pressed in how do we not only use the
competition rules we have already but
how do we make sure that they are
relevant in a digital age there are a
number of suggestions in the report from
the special advisors from the input that
we have got from the markets from the
contributions and our conference in in
January that I think is very important
to see well what can we do to make sure
that we don't allow a market to tip and
that may happen sooner in a digital
economy than in a non digital economy
you see economies of scale being a
completely different creature when
things go digit
we have data as a barrier to entry as an
essential resource for innovation for
making your algorithms relevant so there
are a number of more regulatory issues
that we'll have to come back to because
as far as I see it right now of course
the individual cases we need to do those
and we will continue to do those but we
cannot just have the case work to pave
the way for a fair competitive market
when everything is go digital so there
is indeed a need for a push in that
direction second when we discuss
Industrial Policy one of the things that
are obvious is that there's at least
three things that any relevant
Industrial Policy will have to fulfill
first it has to be relevant for all of
Industry because the European industry
comes from the very big companies to the
quite small companies but all playing a
role in that very fabric of the European
business structure second that it is
climate change would you say kosher
because everything will have to be
looked through that prism because if you
don't well then we will have no chance
of meeting the targets that we have set
ourselves and thirdly of course an
industrial policy you will have to have
its paces in wanting to have fair
competitive markets because otherwise
there is a risk that we place the cost
of having an industrial policy you know
in places in the value chain where we
don't really want it that costs to
replace or were the final consumers so
in that respect I think for the next
coming months it is very important that
we keep discussing what do we need in
order to make sure that Europeans and
European businesses can have the benefit
of a fair competitive market in Europe
and that I welcome anyone who wants to
participate in that debate I think this
is triggered more appetite Tibor excuse
me everyone is hungry probably two
questions from the two conversation we
just had
you have just mentioned the three thing
that industrial policy should be about
should we understand that there are
discussion that industrial policy will
be part of your portfolio in next
commission the second question is about
competition rules reform in president
van der Leyen speech before the
Parliament there were no mention at all
about competition there were some
mentioned about competitiveness but not
common law reform does it mean that it
will not be a priority for the next
Commission well since no one has got
their portfolios yet or they're sort of
mission letter yet I think we're all
free to express interests of almost
everything and I think this we're
talking about now it is you know I love
this expression it dovetails with
competition law enforcement as such so
in that respect now I think it is just
very important that we see things also
holistically and second I think I don't
know but I think that the speaking time
of the president nominee was limited in
Parliament now she's the president-elect
and we'll of course detail the program
for the next five years I'm absolutely
certain that's how to make competition
law enforcement relevance in a digital
era will be part of that working program
I don't think one should at all exclude
that or include that on the basis of
that in my opinion very inspiring speech
in the European Parliament Tuesday do we
have any new questions
push it down commissioner would you be
this serious of having competition law
as one of your key portfolios as as VP
but it's it's very difficult to answer
that kind of questions as you know in in
this mandate I've had one piece of
legislation to empower national
competition authorities to be able to do
more to get the digital evidence to get
the necessary independence resources I
don't think that's legislation within
the competition portfolio in itself
fully can sort of fill up your working
day in the competition portfolio in
itself there will be very interesting
debates not only when it comes to sort
of the regulations but also to the state
guidelines you probably know that we
have launched a fitness check to see if
our rules are fit for purpose and that
result will come back in the next
mandate in order to see what what should
we do to make sure that saying it rules
is an enabler of fair competition and
not something that is felt as a
time-consuming detail mongering exercise
but something that enables fair
competition within the single market so
there will be a lot of sort of echo
Latorre guideline work to do in the next
mandate but how we will organize that
that remains to be seen
thank you thank you Joe Barnes from The
Daily Express
so to comment on some of your colleague
Ron Simmons words he said the the
Commission to start treating Britain
more harshly so with Britain's new prime
minister being elected next week how do
you think they should be treated by the
Commission and do you share his thoughts
that Teresa Mays brexit negotiation team
were running around like idiots thank
you what just to put it very straight
forward as long as the UK is a member of
the European Union I think it should be
treated as a member of the European
Union and when the UK is not a member of
the European Union I hope that we will
establish a new close relationship
no none whatsoever I think we had the
last question from David back there
thank you david prosser your democracy I
have a question about the competition
and choice of Commissioners originally
the term independent which is one of the
main conditions for choice of
commissioners meant that they weren't
allied to any government interests
political party or other organization
and there have been a number of
candidates who are not up this time who
are not members of political parties
political parties when the community
started represented 15% of the
population is membership and now it was
only sort of 2% of the population who
are members of political parties and I'm
wondering whether the political parties
are showing an unfair dominance of the
choice of commissioners and there isn't
a real good choice of commissioners and
proper competition in the 500 million
people who could be open to put
themselves forward as candidates
provided they have the age and
experience
I really appreciate the efforts of
putting the question into a sort of a
competition portfolio it's a very
interesting question because the
European democracy is unique in its
nature it's also unique in this nature
that we have the sources of legitimacy
from our Member States in in council and
from our directly with elected
representatives in Parliament and then
we have the Commission and I I take that
independence very seriously it made a
big impression for me when we took the
bus all new commissioners to Luxembourg
and in front of 37 judges in their ropes
literally at the hand on the treaty to
swear not to take instructions not to
seek instructions but to do what was in
the treaty because the treaty is a
promise that every member state have
signed up to be course mall or whenever
we became a member and and that of
course is is the balance you may come
and be named by governments it may rely
on your party affiliation but look at my
own country it's now a social democratic
government and they called me to
continue as commissioner being from the
social Liberal Party so it's not you
know always one-to-one the governing
party is sending someone from the
governing party but I think the
expectation on each and every one of us
when we hopefully are confirmed by the
Parliament to serve on the Commission
that we serve in a collegial way that
every member state no matter their
government will have equal treatment by
the Commission I know that is a
complicated unique way of having a
democracy
I very much like it because I think it's
very much a reflection of European
history and European geography thank you
I'm afraid with this we will have to
conclude the press conference and
but they will start shortly thank you
thank you thank you